Je veux un parc d'attraction !!
Un jour, Michael Jackson lui aussi a eu cette idée
Sauf qu'il avait les thunes pour la réaliser
Pas moi ! Mais j'ai les thunes d'acheter un jeu pour faire un parc d'attraction. C'EST LONG !!
Oh on a battu le record de longueur de l'intro la plus longue du monde
Je vous présente SQUEEZIE dans 20 ans
voila quand il bidera sur youtube et qu'il se sera mis au vin rouge que son nez aura triplé de volume et qu'il sera OBÈSE!!!
*rot du personnage*
La bonne nouvelle dans l'histoire c'est que je n'aurais pas de calvitie.
Allez c'est parti on va créer un avatar je vois pas a quoi sa sert on veut pas le voir le mec qui crée le parc il est dans l'ombre, il est la il encaisse les billets c'est tout
Alors l'objectif attirer 800 visiteurs et construire 2 attractions
Alors déjà qui sont ces gens qui tirent sur la foule ça va pas ou quoi vous êtes fous vous voulez faire fuir les clients? Ok, donc le parc est minuscule hein finalement, il est pas très grand
Il est même minuscule
Là on a l'attraction du coup pour les bébés Cadum
Je sais que t'as pas entendu ce mot depuis très longtemps
Mais est-ce que j'peux faire une attraction ici ?
C'est très propice y'a une attraction
Allez ! Qu'est-ce qu'on a ? Le Wild Blue
Heey les gens ils vont kiffer ça ! Je vais le mettre là hein
En mode osef, on va l'mettre juste à côté de l'autre
Voilà comme ça ils ont pas besoin de beaucoup marcher pour y aller
Hop là c'est en place, c'est incroyable
Etat d'attraction fermé, pourquoi ?
Ah 'faut qu'je place l'entrée
Elle est là ok, placez la sortie
On va mettre la sortie ici
Ok, et reliez l'entrée à l'allée
Bah c'est très simple . Allez c'est parti ça ouvre !
Le Wild Blue vient d'ouvrir mesdames et messieurs
Ah regardez ils courent pour la faire
En mode oh c'est génial c'est la nouvelle attraction, sponsorisée par Squeezie
Ce gros fils de p*** qui fait des placements d'produits c'est incroyable on y va
Est-ce que ça s'envole ?
Oh regardez elle est heureuse
Prix du billet : 9.00$
*Feel like... I don't give a damn
Voilà un p'tit +50%
Tranquille . WOOOOHOOO !!!!
Des grosses barres
Allez on va continuer on va refaire une attraction
Qu'est-ce qui peut attirer les gens ? Ça c'est nul c'est nul c'est nul
Ça c'est quoi ? Oh c'est bien çaaaa ah oui oui oui !!
C'est validé par la prod
Hop on est bon l'entrée on va la mettre juste devant le truc à guichet
Vraiment PAYE, PAYE BANDE DE SA***ES
Le client est roi chez Squeezie industries
Allez ça ouvre ça ouvre c'est parti c'est la fiesta locabébé
Allez venez jusque là, les amis!
Faudrait que je mette un petit stand de nourritures, t'sais *renifle* pour les attirer, regarde:
Boutique et services, qu'est-ce qu'on a, qu'est-ce qu'on a?
"Grande entrée, conte de fée" ben VOILA!!
Ben VOILA, c'est ça qui nous faut pour attirer les gens!
Comme ça... Voilà!
Ah m**e, je l'ai mal mise!
C'est pas grave, on double clique, on clique sur déplacer
C'est pareil dans la vraie vie, croyez moi
Mon oncle il tient une fête foraine donc, direct tu vas te calmer!
Allez les gens, allez-y, regardez y'a un beau château, vous êtes attirés de ouf!
Ben voilà!
Et encore!!
J'ai pas monté le prix du billet de la deuxième attraction!
Bon bref, ça c'est réussi!
Le mode carrière c'est bien mais franchement c'est pour les débutant
Ben oui! Le parc il est déjà à moitié fait!
Nous on veut du DÉFI!
Et ça tombe bien, parce qu'il y a une catégorie défi!
Où on commence son parc à zéro!
Et on a pas de thunes illimitée
Euuuuh, on fait ça dans quoi?
Alpestre, prairie?
Moi je pense le mieux c'est de faire: désertique
Comme ça y'a pas d'eau, et on vend l'eau hyper chère!
Et on devient riche! Allez!
Ah mais là c'est juste un chemin pour faire du jogging?
On vient de loin quand même!
Est-ce qu'on commence par juste se faire des stands de bouffe?
:rire:
Mec, montagne russe ça compte: 4038$
On a combien d'argent?
4000$ ...
Celui là il est pas mal, "The Madness" vas y on va mettre "The Madness"
WAW!!
Il est pas mal, 'tain il est énorme le truc!
Ça ça coute 3700$, ça?
Mais je le fais dans mon jardin, direct!
OK!
Attends mec, elle est carrément bien!
ça va faire fureur!
y'a des gens qui viennent ou pas?
je crois y'a personne qui vient...
Bah personne vient!
Mais comment j'attire les gens?
Ah y'a deux personnes ça y'est!
Ils s'étaient perdus, ils se faisaient un petit rallye
ils se sont crashés
ils marchent, ils tombent sur quoi?
Mon parc d'attraction!
Ah je vais les mettre bien!
La file d'attente pour The Madness a l'air rapide
Mais y'a personne dans mon parc!
Mais attends mais en plus j'ai mis l'entrée devant des bancs?
Mais chui con!
Les gens vont devoir enjamber le banc pour...
ohlà rien ne va, allez modifs'!
NON!
Mais non j'avais fait un truc nickel et j'ai plus de thune pour...
:rire:
J'ai plus d'argent pour finir ces escaliers qui permettent d'accéder à l'attraction...
Oh putain allez on a fait faillite, c'est reparti!
Ok, alors là on vient de faire un truc génial, les gens ils arrivent, ils rentrent dans le parc
Tout de suite, la file de droite
CLAC! C'est direct pour la file d'attente!
Parce que tu veux tout de suite faire une attraction quand t’arrive!
T'as pas envie de voir mickey faire: "Heeey comment ça va?"
NON!!!
Et je met direct le prix à 12 parce que les gars c'est le début aussi soyez compréhensifs!
Quand on sera une firme multi-milliardaire de parc d'attractions je baisserai les prix
Mais là c'est le début!
:rire:
Je suis le pire businessman du monde!
Ok l'attraction ouvre!
Et là, on accélère le temps c'est parti!
Oh mon dieu ils arrivent!
Ils arrivent!!
Ils arrivent!!!!!!
Vous voyez ces gens?
Nous on voit pas des gens,
nous on voit des billets qui volent!
Oh mon dieu, ils sont en train de faire de l'argent!
C'est en train de faire de l'argent!!
C'est en train de faire du gros bénéfice sa mère!!!
Oh je suis comme un fou!
Oh putain! Mon gars on fait fureur avec une attraction c'est exceptionnel!
Et là attention qu'est-ce qu'on fait?
On repasse en vitesse normale,
et on va tout de suite construire, un petit stand de bouffe!
A la sortie de l'attraction qu'est-ce tu manges?
DE LA BOUFFE!!
Et tu la vomis dans l'attraction d'après et du coup t'en rachètes!
2x plus de bénéfices, 2x plus d'argent!
Bon alors on va mettre le petit cheesebeef
Un peu pourri...
Sinon ça continue de faire de l'argent ou pas là?
Les gens ils en disent quoi?
Ouais c'est cool!
Ça marche, ça cartonne!
Donc ça c'est fait...
Ensuite faut un truc de... des toilettes!
Et 'tain hyper important!
Y'a pas des toilettes normales, ils sont obligés de faire des toilettes à thème
Genre toilettes pirates, toilettes contes de fées, y'a cendrillon dans les toilettes d'à côté!
non!
Bon bozo le clown, non mais c'est flippant mec!
Moi jamais, jamais je me met cul nu dans cet endroit!
Jamais!
Alors la file d'attente, *nana* c'est rapide!
Je pense que je peux rajouter un wagon mec!
Mais j'ai peur de le fermer!
Bon!
Je ferme l'attraction messieurs, dames!
C'est pour votre bien!
Et j'ajoute...
...deux wagons!!
Et je la ré-ouvre!
Alors attends, je suis obligé de la tester avant de la ré-ouvrir
Non partez pas, partez pas!!
Ou alors, vous pouvez faire une petite pause à la buvette elle est vraiment cool!
Ou au burger, y'a pas de souci allez-y!
Oh non, ils rentrent chez eux putain
oh merde!
C'est bon c'est ouvert, vous pouvez revenir!
Revenez bande de p***es!!
Le client est roi chez squeezie industries!
Ah non, ils partent vraiment!
Et puis ils partent, ils déménagent même!
J'ai jamais vu des gens aussi pressés de partir!
*cris*
Ok, y'a du monde qui arrive c'est bon, on est bien!
Les thunes reviennent, les thunes reviennent!
Bon faut que je fasse des toilettes, mec, y'a pas moyen
On va faire le village de conte de fées!
C'est payant les chiottes?
Attends c'est pas payant!
Ça va pas nous rapporter d'argent!
Ohpopop j'ai faillir faire une bêtise là!
Tout ce qui n'apporte pas d'argent dégage!
Bien loin!
Oh les gars!
Le moment tant attendu est arrivé!
On va pouvoir faire le "Wild Blue" mon pote!
HOP! On va le mettre là!
Relier l'entrée à l'allée, c'est très très simple!
Juste à côté des chiottes! Comme ça dans la file d'attente les gars vous allez kiffer les odeurs!!
Voilà, ils rentrent par là, ils ressortent par là!
Et ça dégage, c'est très très bien!
Et mec, je suis content! Ça commence à ressembler à quelque chose ou pas?
Hein?
On a les petites chiottes, la bouffes, deux attractions
Et l'essentiel est là!
Ça c'est vraiment le truc qui a fait fureur!
Vraiment les gens ils sont hyper content...
"The Madness" est en panne?
*cri viril*
EUUUUUUUUUH (Squeezie est perdu) en panne!
Qu'est-ce que je doit faire?
Demander une rénovation!
Allez vas y, on rénove, on rénove, on rénove...
Oh mec, c'est la fin du monde!
Putain heureusement qu'on a la deuxième!
Je comprends pas ils rénovent ou pas?
J'ai dit: "Rénovez"
La satisfaction moyenne des visiteurs baisse
Ben oui, mais l'attraction est tombé en panne!!
Comment je la rénove?
Pourquoi il rénove pas?
Le mec met du temps à venir, c'est ça?
Le mec il fait la rénovation, mais il du temps à venir c'est ça qui se passe?
BAH MEC! Sinon je la vends et j'en refais une!
Je vais faire ça! Vas y, je la vend!
Voilà, the madness...
En plus il m'a rapporté plus que ce qu'il coute?
Ah non, il coute 4000$
Oh le con!
C'est pas grave, je le refait je le refait, je le refait
Mec ça va plus vite!
On s'en bat les couilles nous, on est comme ça!
Allez, on la test et on la relance!
Non mais franchement c'est allé plus vite!
Mais le gars il est dans le bouchon, moi je lui dis, gars, tes bouchons c'est quoi?
Ça va plus vite de reconstruire l'attraction que d'attendre que tu sortes des bouchons!
Rhaa ils lavent pas les détritus!
Putain, d'enculés de gros porcs!
J'ai mis des chiottes là, j'ai mis des chiottes là, et vous jetez des choses!
Putain, mais allez crevez!
Le client est roi chez squeezie industries!
Bon du coup j'ai employé, vla les mécaniciens là!
Bon à la fin du mois ça va me piquer au niveau du prix...
... au mois, là, je peux réparer les trucs en deux-deux!
Madness coute trop cher, mais arrêtez vos conneries!
madness coute pas trop cher du tout!
"La vache, ça coute hyper cher!" ah merde madness coute trop cher c'est vrai!
On va le mettre à 12$
Et 'tain on est pas mal, putain!
L'argent rentre là!!
Bon les gars, il va être temps de mettre une autre attraction, on va pas se mentir!
Qu'est-ce qu'on pouvoir se mettre?
Tu sais un truc un peu familial, tu vois!
Psychola? Bah voilà!
Hop! Et voilà!!
Et on ouvre! Et au niveau des thunes, 6$ c'est pas assez, on va mettre 9$
Voilà! C'EST PARTI!!!
Les gars on commence à avoir 3 attractions!
Deux toilettes!
Un distributeur de billet!
Ah y'a personne!
Ah les gens ils ignorent le distributeur!
Parfait!
Je rénove! On va tout rénover!
Pourquoi personne rénove là?
Bon les gars, vous rénovez ou quoi là?
Attends c'est la chute là, je comprends plus...
Je suis en train de perdre vlà l'argent
Mais REGARDE! Je suis en perte!
A cause de ça qui est fermé, j'ai demandé une rénovation!
Rénovez bordel!
Le problème c'est que j'ai pris trop d'employé là!
J'en ai pris trop pour qu'ils réparent, mais là ils réparent pas!
Oh non, je suis en train de nous mener à notre perte, je suis en train de nous mener à notre perte!
Mayday, mayday, 22, mayday, 22!
Très bien! Ça fait maintenant 4 heures et demi que j'ai demandé la réparation de l'attraction
mais l'ingénieur qu'est-ce qu'il fait? Il se balade dans le parc
Faut en dégager, faut en dégager je les paye alors qu'ils bossent pas, ça va pas du tout...
Faut en dégager là!
Toi! Tu fais quoi?
D'ailleurs t'es viré!
Tu sors!!
Putain on perd trop d'argent,
les gens ils sont pas content,
les toilettes sont vides,
les déchets par terre...
C'est un rêve qui se brise!
Malgré tout ses efforts, Squeezie ne put sauver son parc d'attraction...
C'est la conclusion un peu nulle de cette vidéo!
Vous vous attendez à ce que je dise autre chose?
Mais je n'ai rien à ajouter
Et voilà les gens, c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo sur planète coaster,
J'espère que ça vous a plus si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à liker comme d'habitude, je parle super vite!
N'hésitez pas à l'aimer si ça vous a plu
Moi ça m'a fait marrer, ça fait longtemps que j'avais pas joué à un jeu comme ça,
de simulation, où... Quand j’étais petit je jouais à celui... Zoo Tycoon je crois
où tu fais un putain de zoo avec des animaux!
J'adore les animaux, je l'ai pas dit assez cette semaine, avec le let's play je crois que vous avez pas compris
J'adore les animaux!
Et bien merci d'avoir regardé, peut être qu'on fera un deuxième épisode où cette fois on construira pas dans le désert!
Non, non, non! Les gens dans le désert ils sont vénérs:
ils ont chaud, ils sont déshydratés, ils transpirent, ça pue!
non, non! On le fera, en Antarctique!
A très bientôt pour une nouvelle vidéo, merci d'avoir regardé, merci d'avoir payé pour venir dans mon parc d'attraction!
Je vous dis à très bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo, tchao tout le monde!
Peace!